والقيام بكل ما هو لازم لردع التصعيد
والحؤول دون توسع رقعه هذه الازمه كذلك
تحدثنا عن المستقبل مستقبل هذه المنطقه
واعتقد ان هنك اتفاقا واسع النطاق على
اهداف اساسيه اولاها ان اسرائيل
والاسرائيليين ينبغي ان يتمكنوا من العيش
بسلام
وامن لا
يخشون خوف الارهاب ويعيشون بسلام مع
جيرانهم ثانيا الضفه الغربيه وغزه ينبغي
ان تكون متوحده تحت قياده فلسطينيه وحكم
فلسطيني
ثالثا مستقبل المنطقه ينبغي ان يكون واحدا
مستقبلا يقوم على التكامل وليس الفرقه
والنزاعات والصراعات ورابعا من اجل تحقيق
ذلك نحتاج الى انشاء دوله فلسطينيه مستقبل
مستقله لا احد تحدثت اليه يعتقد ان هذه
الاهداف سهله وسلسه والجميع يدركون
العراقيل والعقبات وان ذلك لن يتحقق بين
ليله وضحاها ولكننا اتفقنا على ان نعمل
معا وان ننسق جهودنا وان نساعد غزه ل
لتنعم بالاستقرار والتعافي وكذلك رسم طريق
مستقبلي لفلسطين والعمل على تحقيق السلام
والامن والاستقرار في المنطقه على المدى
البعيد كذلك وجدت
اتفاقا
ان القاده الذين التقيت
بهم مستعدون وعازمون اتخاذ القرارات
الصعبه من اجل دفع هذه الاهداف قدما ونحن
الان نتوجه الى اسرائيل وامامنا فرصه
لاشار القاعده الاسرائيليين كل ما سمعته
الى الان خلال زيارتي هذه وكذلك لاتحدث
اليهم
بشان المستقبل الحمله
العسكريه في غزه و ساركز على الاهميه
القصوى لبذل مزيد من الجهود لحمايه
المدنيين وكذلك ضمان ان المساعدات
الانسانيه تصل الى محتاجيها وكذلك سنركز
على
جهودنا المستمره
لاعاده الرهائن الى الوطن من امريكيين
واسرائيليين واخرين كذلك سنناقش مستقبل
المنطقه ومستقبل بالنسبه لاسرائيل وانا
على يقين وعلى قناعه بان
هنالك مستقبل مسارا يمكن ان يحقق الامن
والاستقرار لاسرائيل وكذلك يضمن عدم تكرار
ما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر وكذلك يمكن ان
يوحد هذه المنطقه بما يحقق تطلعات وامال
الشعب
الفلسطيني
و بشكل يجعل هذه المنطقه تركز على
المستقبل وليس على تحديات
الماضي انت تتحدث
عن عن منع التمدد
هذا
النزاع موضوع جبهه جديده واستخدام نفوذ
امريكا على اسرائيل
كذلك انتم تفضلون الدبلوماسيه لان اي
هجمات عسكريه يمكن ان تثير التوتر ما هي
رسائلكم رسائل الدول العربيه بشان
الولايات المتحده والتحالف وكذلك النيه
لتشن هجوما على اليمن فيما يتعلق بلبنان
ليس من مصلحه اي طرف سواء اسرائيل او
لبنان او حزب الله لان يرى تصعيدا لمر وان
يكون هنالك صراعا محتملا وا الاسرائيليون
كانوا واضحين تماما معنا يريدون ان يكون
هنالك مسارا
دبلوماسيا يحقق الامن وهنالك اكثر من 100
الف اسرائيل يطر للرحيل من بيوتهم بسبب
التهديدات من حزب الله من لبنان و كذلك
يسمح للبنانيين لنعود الى بيوتهم في جنوب
لبنان ونحن نعمل بلا كل ولا ملل على هذا
الصعيد ون نعمل على ذلك دبلوماسيا اما
فيما يتعلق بالبحر الاحمر الاسره الدوليه
جميعها تواجه تحديا ان تلك الهجمات
المستمره من قبل الحوثيين على التجاره
البحريه الدوليه تمثل تهديدا للجميع وهذا
ما تحدثت عنه امس 15% من حجم التجاره
العالميه يمر عبر ذلك
الممر المائي البحر الاحمر وتلك الهجمات
كان لها تاثير حقيقي على الاسعار التي
التي يدفعها الناس في ما متعلق بالدواء
والغذاء والطاقه والسفن عليها ان تتخذ
مسارات اخرى ما
يرفعوا كلفه التامين لذلك الاسره الدوليه
عليها ان تحافظ على ذلك المبدا هنالك اكثر
من 40 دوله واوضحت بان ما يقوم به
الحوثيون يجب ان يتوقف هنالك دول اخرى او
ضحت بانه اذا ما استمر الحوثيون فان بغك
التبعات لذلك وجهه نظرنا القويه وما نفضله
بشكل قوي هو ان تصل الرساله الى
الحوثيين التي تبعثها دول العالم بان ما
يقومون به ينبغي ان يتوقفوا هذا ما نركز
عليه 14 دوله
عفوا قبل قبل هجمات السابع من اكتوبر
الامم المتحد وغيره من
مساعدي كانوا يتحدثون عن تطبيع العلاقات
السعوديه وعلى ما يبدو ان الامر بات صعبا
وعصيا على ضوء ما حدث ومشاعر العداء لدى
الاطراف المختلفه ولكنكم ما زلتم تصرون
على المضي قدما لانكم تعتقدون ان هنالك
طريقه واحده لان لتعمل اسرائيل على تحقيق
تطلعات وامال الشعب الفلسطيني ما الذي قال
له ماذا الذي قاله ولي العهد محمد بن
سلمان بشان ذلك الموضوع وما هي الظروف
والشروط التي يمكن ان تحقق التطبيع وما
الذي يمكن ان تقدمه الولايات المتحده
ليتحقق او ليتم التوصل الى اتفاق التطبيع
ثانيا هل ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان ومحمد
بن زايد هل اخبرك ما الذي يتعاد على
الولايات المتحده ان تقوم به عقب نهايه
هذه الحرب فيما يتعلق بالسؤال
الثاني في كل محطه توقفت فيها وجدت رغبه
لدى كل الدول الضالع
والمشاركه بان تقوم بامور مهمه لتساعد على
تحقيق الاستقرار في غزه وبعث الحياه فيها
مره اخرى وهذا ما وجدته في كل المحطات
واحد الامور التي سنعمل عليها معا
هو ما هو المطلوب وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه
الدول او ما اذا هذا هو الامر الاساس اما
فيما يتعلق بالتكامل والتطبيع نعم
بالتاكيد ناقشنا ذلك في كل المحطات بما في
ذلك في السعوديه واقول لك ان هنالك مصلحه
واضحه شان السعي وراء ذلك وهنالك مصلحه
للمنطقه برمتها فيما يتعلق بتحقيق ذلك
الهدف ولكن هذا سيتطلب نهايه او انتهاء
الصراع في غزه وكذلك ان يكون هك مسارات
عمليه تقود وتفضي الى دوله فلسطينيه هذا
ما سمعته من جميع من تحدثت اليهم اذا
الاهتمام موجود والمصلحه موجوده وهو حقيق
ويمكن ان تكون تحولي وقابلا للتحقيق شكرا
ج نتفي بهذا القدر